changement de visage pour le quartier de
la Noé à Chanteloup-les-Vignes après la
démolition d'un immeuble et de quelques
travaux de réaménagement urbains les
chantes Louvet pourront bientôt profiter
de la nouvelle place des petits pas ce
sera un lieu qui sera extrêmement vert
avec 65 arbres nouveau on a besoin d'y
l'autre fraîcheur idée c'est vraiment de
proposer de l'ombre des endroits où on
peut s'asseoir devant on peut s'apaiser
et des endroits où on peut un peu
profiter de l'été sinon c'est un peu
c'est un peu compliqué conçu pour
améliorer la qualité de vie des
habitants la place des petits pas
donnera aussi accès à la future cité
éducative Simone Veil qui débutera ses
travaux en 2024 puisqu'on va regrouper
collège et col élémentaire sur un même
site de façon à ce que la rupture de
l'encre en 6e qui est terrible pour les
enfants et en particulier dans ces
grandes cités soit amortie par la
coexistence dans un même ensemble qui
est la cité éducative donc c'est à la
fois
un projet
urbain au sens du béton mais c'est aussi
un projet humain l'urbain étant au
service de l'humain la cité éducative
Simone Veil ouvrira ses portes en 2028